a man pushes the women just before yeah
the podium collapses and they all fall
it has looked like it's been there a
while there's some green algae on it do
we touch up the woman misjudges her jump
I would say it looks like a misjudgment
already he's wondering is this date
gonna work out in his face right now
what do you think I'll go over you on
those I think the day it's gonna work
out oh god I think she's gonna misjudge
her jump okay go for it see total
misjudgment at least the song yes at
least yes it didn't look like she got
hurt she could have definitely caught
ash in there okay somebody's gonna open
the door here or is he gonna jump on top
of her yeah okay let's see the woman
accidentally kicks both kids in the
price essential definitely high
potential oh yeah yeah he looks like
he's got mischief in his mind he's a
future inmate yeah the woman lets out a
fart and the kids can't stop laughing
awesome
oh good potential I'm gonna say the
child opens the door I know for me I'm
working mom and we're hoping that I'm
gonna really hurt him he's on the toilet
pool
yeah
and he knows he's funny oh yes oh sorry
a jumper yes she knows something's
happening here she's gonna she's trying
to be something in there what's in the
bin a squirrel a snake where are we you
know London could be a green snake a man
man Thank You squirrel okay I'm gonna go
with you yeah how did the squirrel get
me the Biz that's the question
oh yeah this is the classic across the
creek just thinking about it too much
don't think who falls in the river the
man a woman is there another option is
there another squirrel the boogey man
both of them oh I'm gonna go with both
because that right leg looks like it's
gonna slip on the banking they were
going for that option what was that
Missy she really pulled him in she
really did she looks like she's annoyed
with him he's not getting out of my way
get her up on the banking gentlemen oh
witness they're not even amused what are
they still doing in there come on guys I
once I once dropped my phone in a stream
just like this and realized the banner a
half later went by waded through the
stream and this self finally found my
form but in a bowl of rice for 24 hours
what fine amazing I know what phone was
that
no advertising poeple like to send me
one of your marvelous water-resistant
wife's friendly hoods Ganesha
okay guy going in barefoot that's key in
barefoot in the toilet no a nice feeling
slippers slippers are essential what
surprise awaits this guy in the toilet a
guy with an ak-47 a rat in the toilet
right
his mom has turned the toilet into the
islands what is the Iron Throne it's a
game of Thrones then I'm his mom has got
a toilet seat made with his face on it
his mum has had a special toilet and so
for the dog to use okay well what
divergent wait I'm gonna I'll go with
your eye on the phone you don't have to
feel obligated now we've come this far
we've come this far then you resent me
afterwards the fest a little bit just a
little bit there's a dog behind him no
[ __ ] just notice that let's pull it by
it's too late oh yeah she's like wait
till he gets in there golfers I almost
got hit by golf ball
the caddy and the guy that I was
caddying with did get hit by the golf
ball it was one of the funniest things
I've ever seen and I shouldn't be so
we're going to find positions behind
trees and he was like I'm going for a
piss if the ball comes my way let me
know so anyway he was over there
studying taking a piss and the ball you
know we've got hit but basically he
cowered Oh still going with that and the
ball just kind of like an ax laser found
him went through the trees and popped
off his back was like crying on the
train laughing there's a piece of art
and actually the funny part of the story
was like you called first they were
English he was like oh my god that's
terrible because I was laughing told him
a story and they're like oh my god it's
lucky it didn't hit you in the head and
he goes he goes just lucky it didn't hit
me in the nob potentia our man dressed
as a golf ball runs by them on the
course I prefer to see the bird poop the
golf ball explodes I'll go for the one
that I really want to see which is the
bird poop back over yep yeah
[Music]
I thought we were playing the game
together I didn't think we were against
each other oh wait we're against